all right now we'll get to five
headlines
[Music]
number one joe biden made some waves
yesterday when he got out of bed for the
first time in four weeks and did an
interview and during this interview he
accused trump of being not only
a racist but the first racist president
we've ever had watch
no sitting president has ever done this
never
never never no republican president has
done this no democratic president
we've have racists and they've existed
they've tried to get elected president
he's the first one that has
now i actually love this from biden and
i'll tell you why it's com
it completely undermines the effort of
the anti-statue squad
they've torn down jefferson washington
lincoln
roosevelt others all on the basis
that those guys were racist and now
biden is saying no none of them were
raises trump is the first racist one
which is great it's obviously
nonsensical and not true but it's great
also to note here we're numb to this
by now but you know and some of you
young whippersnappers might not realize
this but
it used to be a big deal
to call a president racist that that
used to be something that you didn't
just go around
saying um even recently
kanye west 15 years ago relatively
recently
called george bush a racist and it was a
huge controversy
people were talking about it for weeks
after that people still talk about it
that's how big of a deal it was and now
the dems call trump a racist as a matter
of course
every day they call them that they wake
up in the morning and that's the first
thing they say they just wake up and
trump's a racist all right let's start
today it's it's it's compulsive it's a
compulsion now for them and the effect
of course is that the word has lost all
meaning so
ironically the men like bush who were
merely called racist
uh you know once every few months
were more successfully painted as racist
because at least back then the word
racist still had some sort of meaning
number two a couple of pictures i want
to show you here first look at this
mug shot that that right there you're
looking at that's a scumbag named isaiah
jackson
um i want you to take a a good look at
this monstrous
piece of dirt there he is and
so you don't think i'm being harsh in my
description of him
here's the picture that got him arrested
take a look at that
there he is kneeling on a toddler's neck
uh with the caption
blm now actually says blm now mother
effer
and that apparently is his girlfriend's
child the mother the girlfriend
uh allegedly was unaware that this
picture was being taken she wasn't she
was in the house but didn't know
about this supposedly i find that hard
to believe personally i mean the child
was in distress clearly obviously
screaming because he was in pain and he
was terrified
uh did she not realize that did she not
hear it did she not wonder why her son
was screaming in fear while alone in the
room with her dirtbag scumbag
boyfriend i don't know um
whether she was aware or not this guy's
going to jail uh
and and and hopefully now
there are two other people involved
there there's someone taking a picture
and there's also someone holding the
child's arms back and i think at this
point police still aren't sure who those
other people are
i you know again you have to wonder
whether it was the mother
but uh you know the police say it wasn't
okay
all i'll say is i can only hope that
some of the other prisoners
in whatever prison he goes to see that
picture
and decide that they want to have a good
long talk with mr jackson about it
that's all just to talk that's all i
would be hoping for
just just the kind of talk that
prisoners have with other prisoners who
harm children in that way um maybe
that'll
help them see see the light
in more ways than one three now uh this
is kind of redundant at this point but
let me play you another clip this is
congressman bobby rush of illinois
being interviewed by talk radio host joe
madison and reacting to trump's plans to
send troops or
not troops so i'm already i'm already
using their
they've got me now uh they've
conditioned me to call to
to send in federal law enforcement to
chicago now russia's
73 years old he's a 14
term congressman okay he's been in
congress for 14 terms
and if you want to know whether rush was
re-elected 14 times because he's just
that sharp and brilliant and competent
well listen to this i think that when
trump is ready to sign the new
uh uh my my friend i think that
trump is really trying to instigate a
race war
he wants to have a reaction everybody
mean these armed agents uh are deployed
into toronto
there's some guys that you know that
ain't going to accept that
i mean they're not he if he sends them
in
he better not send them into uh the
encore
the south side west side you might have
seen them
uh send them over to the uh gentile
north side
because their name coming then i'm not
advocating that but i didn't know
that that's what trump's game plan trump
wants
to instigate a race war he want to have
black people so he didn't rise up and
say
i'm the real uh red
wizard of the truth club clan and i'm
the president
he re-elected me that's what he's trying
to do he's trying to
paint um playing to the uh interference
to any uh racial animus that exists
among certain white people and he will
do everything and anything
to uh do that because he wants to meet
reelected at all i did you a favor there
i only played you a fraction
of russia's babbling answer uh he
actually begins by saying
he he's asked this all started because
he was asked
by the the host what does he think about
this plan
and he he uh what you what i just played
there was about three minutes into his
answer
and the first three minutes were just as
incomprehensible as what you just heard
but he does begin by calling the federal
law enforcement
officers armed bandits he actually calls
them bandits
and then another point he calls them
militia and then he transitions into
trump wanting a race war and trump being
the grand wizard of the kkk
yeah it's trump who wants a race war
right it's donald trump is the one
trying to start a race war
it's not the people like bobby rush
and any other democrat and people in the
media
who are going out there telling uh you
know black americans that
that that white cops are on on the hunt
on the prowl trying to execute them in
the street
just for the crime of being black no
that that's not what's starting a race
war is it
telling this lie of systemic racism i
mean from from
relentlessly continuously
telling people that uh that you know
that
that white people are engaged in some
sort of conspiracy to discriminate and
oppress them
that they're in a systemically racist
country it's always been racist
it's it's inherently racist everything
about it is racist
and again they're being they're being
hunted and executed by racist white cops
no that's not the thing that's going to
start a race war not at all no it's
donald trump
sending in law enforcement officers to
stop people from burning down federal
buildings
number four we know that teen vogue has
some
wacky far left stuff here's the latest
from them headline
joe rogan is spreading transphobic hate
speech and it's putting lives
in danger let me read a little bit from
this it says joe rogan is one of the
biggest figures in podcasting his show
the joe rogan experience
consists of lengthy often rambling
interviews with a diverse array of
athletes
academics actors entrepreneurs and more
but you could also say that rogan has
really built his audience through
selecting guests who bring their own
notoriety to the show
um blah blah blah okay
a lot of times there's it's harmless fun
and then there are the episodes which by
virtue of rogan's massive online reach
lend a veneer of credibility to some
truly dangerous prejudices
take the recent episode with guest
abigail schreier
during schreier's conversation with
rogan which she promoted her book
irreversible damage the transgender
craze seducing our daughters
um sounds like a great book i actually
have to pick that up schreier in
here's the part schreier invalidated the
lived experience of trans and non-binary
kids and teens
and made numerous dangerous entirely
unsound
false equivalencies um then it goes on
some more saying uh you know rogan is
is horrible and bigoted and then it says
which is worse to expose such bigotry to
your millions of subscribers because you
genuinely endorse it
or to have so little conviction that you
will knowingly platform hate speech
about some of the most vulnerable
persecuted young people in our society
to benefit your own
career you be the judge both are
appalling in their own way
and it goes on by the way i lied
this is not a teen vogue article this is
in men's health
yes men's health magazine a magazine
allegedly published to serve an audience
of adult males
and it contains an article vilifying joe
rogan for not believing that females
have penises
and it includes phrases like invalidated
the lived experience of trans kids and
teens
um or sorry trans and non-binary kids
and teens
i hope i didn't just invalidate their
experience by excluding them
accidentally just there now i ask you
has any heterosexual adult male ever
ever non-ironically said the phrase
invalidated the lived experience
i mean has any has any such male uh ever
even said the phrase transphobic hate
speech
so who is this article supposed to
appeal to well we know that these days
everything all things everywhere
must first and foremost serve our
leftist cultural overlords
which is why a men's magazine article
could be lifted and transplanted
into teen vogue intact and it wouldn't
seem out of place at all
and in fact i i checked it right before
i came on the air uh
it was written by philip ellis this
article in men's health
and he actually does write for teen
vogue too so that probably tells you
everything you know
um you know and admittedly i don't know
i don't know who exactly buys these
men's lifestyle magazines
um but i would
imagine that whatever the audience is
it's probably not
an audience for content like that what
do i know
five uh finally a bit of good news for
you so you don't have to worry
about this anymore thankfully according
to the huffington post producers
at the hallmark channel are in quote
active negotiations to include more
lgbtq people in their christmas
movies thank god uh it's you know
because this this is this is a problem
we'd all
spent nights worrying about lost a lot
of sleep over because you know
in fact just last year i was watching a
hallmark christmas movie with my kids
and i thought to myself are there any
non-binary trans
pansexuals in this movie
by the way spoiler there weren't not a
single one
uh it was pretty outrageous but hallmark
fortunately is solving that problem
because like i said before remember who
we must serve first and foremost
hallmark their job just like men's
health magazine
you would think their job is to serve
and provide content for
adult males no it's to serve and provide
content for
our leftist overlords and same for
hallmark you'd think that you know their
audience
christian conservative families nope not
not them
um actually six here's a little bonus
here because i enjoyed this i want to
throw this in
this is from a guy named peter thatchell
i don't know who he is or what he does
his bio says he's quote for human rights
democracy global justice and lgbti
freedom
so i guess that's what he does i
answered my question here's his here's
his tweet
appears to be non-ironic i don't think
this is satire he says
uk's head of state is first born
descendant of each generation of the
all-white senior royals
black and asian people are therefore
excluded from being head of state for a
foreseeable future this
is institutional racism yes the royal
family is racist
for not being black that's the how dare
they not be black
they should have really thought about
this before they decided to not be black
you know you need you need to think
twice honestly a white person's choice
to be white rather than black is tacky
at best
but really peter's right is actually
racist of course we
we're just gonna ignore the fact i guess
that a black woman did marry into
the royal family and then promptly took
the prince and left to america to become
an actress
so that doesn't matter though the real
problem here is that the queen of
england is
is you know if she was black
then we wouldn't have an issue but
every day she decides to continue being
white
what a racist scumbag
with all due respect well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt walsh
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content